ابو وديع يواجه اصعب فراق الحكم على منه
شلبي النصر يحتفي بكريستيانو رونالدو
مواجهه مرتقبه مع ميسي ورفاقه في موسم
الرياض وبطوله خليجي تنطلق في البصره
اليكم الابرز الاسبوع الماضي
[موسيقى]
الاسبوع الثاني على التوالي لا يزال سلطان
الطرب جورج وسوف محطه اهتمامه وسائل
الاعلام ورواد مواقع التواصل في العالم
العربي ولكن هذه المره تعاطفا مع حزنه
الكبير لوفاه نجله الاكبر وديع الذي وري
الثرى في مسقط راس والده في بلده الكفرون
في محافظه طرطوس غربي سوريا وفي لفته
مؤثره وجه ابو وديع المثقل بالحزن رساله
فيديو لمتابعه عبر حسابه الرسميه على
فيسبوك ناشد فيها ابناء بلدته بعدم اطلاق
الرصاص خلال مراسم التشهير
اللي يرجع كثير كبير عندكم
ما بدي اسمع صوتك
وقعدت وفاه الشاب وديع جورج وسوف الجدل
الى الواجهه حول مخاطر عمليات تكميم
المعده والتي افادت تقارير اعلاميه
لبنانيه بان مضاعفاتها كانت وراء وفاته
والى مصر حيث صدر الحكم في معاقبه الفنانه
منه شلبي بالحبس لمده عام مع ايقاف
التنفيذ وتغريمها 10000 جنيه بتهمه حيازه
جوهر الحشيش المخدر بقصد التعاطي وذلك حسب
ما اكد محاميها في تصريحات خاصه
يوازي البراءه بعد قرار وقفه تنفيذ الحبس
ودفع الغرامه
وفي خبر اخر من مصر تفعل محبه الفنانين
ايمي سمير غانم وحسن الرداد مع اعلان
الثنائي ولاده طفلهما الاول فادي بحسب ما
نشر الرداد عبر حساباته الرسميه على مواقع
التواصل وربما يضع هذا الخبر السعيد حدا
للشائعات التي طالت علاقتهما منذ زواجهما
في العام 2016
والى السعوديه والحدث الابرز الاسبوع
الماضي كان استقبال كريستيانو رونالدو
رسميا في الرياض كواحد من تشكيله فريق
النصر السعودي في كره القدم وسط الترحيب
وتفاعل كبيرين على مواقع التواصل في
المملكه لكن كريستيانو لن يشارك في
مباريات فريق النصر لمده اسبوعين على
الاقل حيث يتعين عليه تنفيذ عقوبه ايقافه
مباراهتين والتي فرضها الاتحاد الانجليزي
لكره القدم في نوفمبر الماضي وقد يكون
الحدث الاكثر اثاره الذي يترقبه عشاق كره
القدم في العاصمه السعوديه المباراه
المنتظره بين فريق
النصر والهلال السعودي وفريق باريس سان
جيرمان على كاس موسم الريال والذي قد يشهد
مواجهه جديده بين اسطولتي كره القدم ميسي
ورونالدو
واخيرا احتفل عشاق كره القدم في العراق
بانطلاق فعاليات بطوله كاس خليجي 25 في
البصره ووسف حفل الافتتاح بالمبهر لكن هذه
الفرحه التي طال انتظارها عكرها اعراب
اتحاد كره القدم الكويتي عن استيائه
الشديد مما وصفه في بيان على تويتر بسوء
التنظيم في مراسم حفل الافتتاح ومنتج عنه
من تدافع عن جماهيري وازدحام شديد تسبب في
تعذر دخول ممثل امير الكويت وقد استدعى
ذلك بيانا من اتحاد كره القدم العراقي
اعرب فيه عن اسفه الشديد لخروج بعض الامور
التنظيميه عن اطارها الصحيح واعتذر للوفد
الكويتي عما حدث